how well can you see your customers with
an illuminated 360-degree view you can
create personalized experiences that
help keep your customers for life we
need to be more customer focused and
more customer centric every organization
everywhere across every industry needs
to focus on how they create that
differentiated personal experience data
is the key to illuminating your
customers it requires you to re-evaluate
your entire ecosystem leveraging every
bit of data from everywhere from your
existing systems to sensors to business
partners to cognitive services that
we've been talking about unfortunately
most enterprises lack that complete view
of their customers no two customers we
have had exactly the same systems we
need to be able to customize our
business process to work with these
different users to illuminate your
customers you need to generate insights
from all the data available to you
whether that data lives in the cloud or
in an on-premises environment whether it
is streaming in from IOT sensors or
being collected from mobile apps and
social platforms capitalizing on all
that data requires a new approach to
integration delivering this demands
entirely new ways of accessing combining
information and requires a new way of
looking at and thinking about
integration IBM cloud integration is
designed to give you access to all your
data so you can better connect to your
customers and power your digital
business a single platform IBM cloud
integration allows you to create deploy
manage and secure api's in minutes forge
connections among apps with
drag-and-drop simplicity support
cognitive API integration secure your
messaging queue from end to end without
slowing down operations and transfer
very large files fast about controlling
bandwidth costs welcome to a landscape
of constantly emerging possibilities
with a complete view of all your data
you can confidently build those
indispensable customer experiences a
business could send status updates on
its delivery trucks so customers know
when to expect their packages we are
able to track trucks in real time we
have a fleet of more than 25,000 drums
everything that we've done today with
the API allow us to gain the customer's
attention all the time building strong
customer experiences can boost customer
loyalty and benefit your bottom line if
your data is in the dark so are your
customers bring your valuable data into
the light where it belongs
[Music]